non les agents manie quoi n'ont pas fait
la moitié de leur travail elles les
pelouses sont tendus tous les quinze
jours depuis plusieurs mois la commune
s'occupe de ses espaces verts avec la
gestion différenciée gestion
différenciée touche différents types
d'espacés justement que ce soit des
espaces verts ou des espaces fleuris et
donc on a eu cette volonté d'avoir une
gestion plus économe plus écologique de
l'ensemble de nos espaces verts c'est
dans les techniques dans les essences
utilisées
on essaye d'avoir quelque chose de plus
durable qui nécessite moins
d'intervention qu'ils soient plus
économes en eau pour les parterres de
fleurs des vivaces peu gourmandes en eau
sont plantés et du paillage de chambre
est répandu pour garder l'humidité
on va essayer au fur et à mesure de les
supprimer complètement les annuelles et
bisannuelles de manière à faire des
vraies économies y compris en achats de
matières premières
chaque année c'est une politique mise en
place avec des tâtonnements une
réflexion collective une formation
collective en apprend au fur et à mesure
on a pris ensemble
donc on a mis en place une formation
avec un spécialiste gestion différenciée
chaque année magny les hameaux investi
entre 10 et 13 mille euros avec la
gestion différenciée elle devrait
diviser par deux ce budget